in seoul's we talk a lot about disparity
about what lies between light and dark
life-and-death heat and cold and today
we discuss two different absolutes we
discuss what lies between those with
power and those without and in this case
what lies between them is a wall a stone
wall that appeared quite suddenly
cementing this divide between hollows
and the nobles who control them and mind
you wall or not there has always been a
divide in the days of Lordran
humanity was a rising force and as a
result they were feared imprisoned and
shepherded they were taught to fear the
undead rising in their ranks in
drangleic the undead were subjugated
once more of course but they were also
experimented upon and all the while they
were expected to sacrifice themselves as
Gwyn once did to keep those Royals in
power and now in lothric the unhindered
born of the ash of these unending
sacrifices journeys through a small town
of suffering undead it was here where a
thief once fancied himself a martyr for
the poor it was the state of this town
that drove grey rat to climb the wall
and gray rat the thief was once a
well-known name until I ended up rotting
so the head covering he wears was once
used to cover the heads of the lesser
folk people who were set to work as
slaves throughout lothric but
occasionally it was used to shame and
humiliate criminals we have reason to
believe that grey rat was indeed a slave
to the kingdom once for he knows the
castle grounds well but here in lower
lothric gray rat is caught and
imprisoned for the very first time ah
even no chill air are you know know
you're from far away and judging by the
Bell you must be some of that I'm kind
of ash remarkable if that's true and I
have a favor to ask below the high wall
is a musty little town not the home of
any Lord just a very old settlement of
undead an old woman Loretta lives there
please give her this ring I'm not asking
for charity
in fact if you do this for me I'll be
sure to repay you
in kind
I may be a petty thief but have more
wits than worst royalty what do you say
that very well I humbly place my faith
in you
I am gray rat of the undead settlement
and I promise to assist you give this
ring to okhla Rhett at the base of the
high wall do your part and I'll do mine
we can't know who Loretta was we don't
know why her corpse clutches a bone nor
do we know what gray rats relationship
to her was the one detail we do know is
that the little rare ring he gives us to
give to her is a tear stone which has
the uncanny ability to sense imminent
death protecting its wearer in their
final moments so whoever she was to him
it seems he cared for her and sensed her
death was close heaven--the
she was already dead thank you God I'm
not surprised though almost a relief
really you can keep the ring
as well a little trinket of thanks I
suppose and he breaks his composure when
you appear back and from then on
dedicates himself fully to your course
ah there you are I was thinking you know
I'm a Betty thief well perhaps I'll go
on the prowl
everyone's dead or hollowed away anyway
right so I might as well fetch some
weapons or treasure for you well what do
you say thank you you will not be
disappointed I will leave for some time
so long for now do stay safe you hear
all my efforts will have been for naught
don't take gray rats robbery of the
undead settlement lightly it was his
home it was the poor there who inspired
him to climb the wall and risk his life
and it was a settlement where he cared
deeply for someone his thievery of the
settlement is kind of an admission that
everyone there no longer matters to him
you do and so emboldened by his new
purpose
he asks to put himself in harm's way
once again
oh hello fine work I say discovering
aerosol in the boreal valley all in a
day's work if the tales are true it is
home to all wound worshiping Nobles and
should be packed with treasure
what do you think shall I go and see
what I can find
mmm a fine choice I am gray rat the
thief what I bring back will be worthy
of that name that name is also known by
others ah I see you made me rent a
slinking remand but he did me a good
turn back in LA trick dungeon there was
I should do something about that little
date well maybe not
well probably believe he's still
standing
this is patches the hyena the spider the
unbreakable by now we have a pretty good
grasp of his character and it's this
same character who for the first time
expresses a genuine concern about the
well-being of another hey what happened
- right right anyhow I haven't seen him
at all lately if you know where he
scurried off to be sure and tell me that
I need to stock up and if he's gone
unquote he'll have left of old mine
right
yes I see aranese
some things can't be divulged even
between Freight it comes with the
territory final but if you happen to
recall any details dubious ain't do it
for old patches boutique of wonders at
least a if patches is still alive to
tell you this then it means you've
forgiven him for a great deal of things
you've forgiven him for impersonating
the onion night for locking you in a
tower he's tried to kill you twice now
probably and it's understandable right
that you wouldn't want to tell him where
your friend has gone however gray rat
can be saved by the very thief you tried
to protect him from well happened to
recall anything important about where
they don't rat scary dollar too well but
all the way to where I feel as he it
can't be much left of that frozen spool
the whole track he's gone off the deep
end this time was gray rat truly saved
by siegward here it's possible or rather
was he saved by an impersonator who was
protecting their reputation oh then
we're both safe and sound
thank the gods for that I don't like
getting things so close I might have
died if it wasn't for that peculiar
onion night but any and it all paid off
take a good look they're sure to be of
some use you know I was thinking about
leaving for another round of thieving
there must be something of use in love 3
Castle I'm aware of the danger that
castle is a death trap not a single man
has returned from the castle unscathed
even back in the day but I don't want to
sit around and die and Betty rant and I
consider myself your friend of to
loitering
the castle of men return
an old thieves lost in everything's here
chanting there
it's hardly new to this game what's got
into his debt repaid even patches
wouldn't risk lothric for a friend but
gray rad will he risks it for us self
sacrifices in his character after all
but I don't think we're the only reason
he goes think back to when he hid his
grief over Loretta - how he's so
absorbed that he doesn't even notice you
immediately after this dives into danger
on your behalf
his sorrow apparently forgotten then you
think that's strange I don't think his
sorrow is forgotten at all I lived a
petty rat but would rather not die as
one gray run the thief
a petty rat looking for an honorable
escape
you